[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we're
reporting live from the Daily Bugle net
studios to bring you a brand new
breakdown of all the pot leaks for the
upcoming Marvel Studios movie the
Eternals these leaks have just dropped
on 4chan and were posted by an anonymous
source yesterday who claims to have
inside knowledge on the movie throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the plot leaks and giving my thoughts on
them there's not a massive amount of
story in here but I still think it's
worth covering as it actually sheds
quite a lot of light on the characters
now there will be heavy spoilers here
and whilst all leaks like this should be
taken with a grain of salt as we saw
with Avengers endgame Game of Thrones
and Joker these sometimes can be true so
if you don't want anything rune then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
Eternals okay so we're going to be going
through the bullet points that were
posted and I'll be giving my thoughts
and how this might work now the first
point says the Eternals are a group of
super-powered immortal alien warriors
created by the cosmic engineers known as
the Celestials they were sent to earth
to protect humankind from the deviants
who are monstrous creatures also created
by the Celestials that have gone rogue
this is interesting because we have had
the Celestials teased throughout the MCU
and we have seen notable concept are of
the godlike creatures that seems to line
up quite a lot with the head of nowhere
appeared in guardians of the galaxy and
infinity war the deviants themselves are
actually the race that Dan are stems
from and there are rumors that the Titan
will be in the film so if this leak is
true it would be an awesome way to bring
him in from here the point states the
Eternals arrived on earth in ancient
times and lived among the humans
throughout the centuries always keeping
their true nature a secret Circe Jemma
Chan is the eternal spy and has psychic
powers her mission is to protect their
secret but she enjoys living among the
humans and wishes
family could reveal their existence of
the world recently we had a leak of JAMA
chan walking through London with a
camera crew following her so she could
indeed be filming for the movie and if
so then this would mean that a lot of it
is set in modern-day Dane Wittman played
by Kit Harington
is an archaeologist who learns about the
Eternals Cersei is sent to erase his
memory but instead they fall in love
leaving Cersei divided between Whitman
and her families this too holds a lot of
weight and with Harrington playing Black
Knight who is rumored to be in the next
Avengers lineup and makes sense to set
their story in modern-day a Jack played
by Salma Hayek is the leader of the
Eternals and his healing powers she
regards the Eternals as a family
particularly because they are not
allowed to have children of their own
this is true to the comics and is one of
the main reasons that the Eternals don't
massively populate the Marvel Universe
so this league I think we'll definitely
be true as it spans from the source
material as do most of the following a
chorus played by Richard Madden is the
mightiest of the Eternals and can
manipulate cosmic energy his loyal and
protective of his family and fiercely
devoted to their mission DNA played by
Angelina Jolie is the deadliest of the
Eternals and has superhuman reflexes
she is brash rebellious and prone to
breaking the rules and carries a great
secret Gilgamesh played by Don Lee is
the strongest of the Eternals and has
superhuman strength and endurance he is
sensitive and humorous despite his
massive size and cares deeply about the
others Macari played by lauren red LOF
is the eternal scout and has superhuman
speed the function is to travel a world
storing knowledge about the humans and
the planet she is a deaf mute and
communicates through sign language Kingo
played by command and journey is the
Eternals wisecracking fun-loving fighter
while the others have chosen to lead
unassuming lives on earth Kingo has used
his abilities to become a world-famous
bollywood movie star fast stars played
by Brian Tyree Henry is the Eternals
inventor he is the most rational of the
group and was once very optimistic but
has since lost his faith in humanity the
plot point says he's also gay which I'll
get into later sprite played by Leah
McHugh is the eternal storyteller and
can create illusions
despite being permanently
in the body of a child she maintains an
upbeat demeanor
Droog played by barry key again is the
most dangerous of the Eternals and can
control people's minds particularly
their fears unlike the others he
despises humans and has its own plans
the movie will span thousands of years
and explore how the Eternals influenced
the history of the MCU before arriving
in modern times which is apparently when
dane whitman discovers the tomb of the
space gods which is capable of summoning
the Celestials to earth to pass judgment
on humankind the Eternals and the
deviants battle for control of the tomb
of the space gods with Whitman caught in
the crossfire
unbeknownst to the Eternals druid is
manipulating both sides and is the
pieces main villain and that's all the
leaks that we have so it sounds like
they're pretty much setting this from a
grounded perspective with Whitman being
the eyes of the viewer as he watches on
and gets caught up in the battle between
what are basically gods whilst there
isn't a lot to unpack here it definitely
sounds like the film will be epic and
I'm glad that they're having expand
millenia so that we can get a true sense
of all the ins and outs of the MCU I'm
getting gradually more and more excited
for the film and it sounds like it's
sticking pretty close to the source
material whilst also integrating with it
in an interesting way that doesn't
necessarily break what we've had so far
as prequels can sometimes do now they're
saying that fastest is gay and we've had
it confirmed by multiple sources that
the film will eat your marbles first
openly gay superhero some outlets have
reported that this is Icarus whereas
this kind of contradicts it so I'm not
sure of its validity but there will
definitely be a gay character in the
film when discussing the matter Richard
Madden who plays Icarus in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly said the
following I think it's hugely important
just the cast is so diverse I'm a white
male actor and not in the majority of
this cast I'm in the minority which is
important in terms of diversity in
filmmaking
I think Marvel are really at the
forefront of that so yeah I think it's
kind of up in the air at the moment
whether it will actually be Icarus or
fastest but it will be interesting to
see how this develops down the line now
the biggest omission for me from this is
the fact that Thanos and the Infinity
stones are missing I think that they
will definitely be in the film
even if they're only teas so hopefully
as more leaks come out they get dropped
in with them overall though I think it
will be a big step for marble and I'm
interested in the film and the cosmic
side of the MCU in general so I'm sure
that they'll do a great job with it
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the leaks and if you're
excited for the film or not comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my ending explain
breakdown of this weekend's big comic
book movie release Joker which you'll be
linked at the end I'll give my thoughts
on the film as well as what we can take
from it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want an in-depth
analysis of the movie if you want to
come chat to me about films TV shows
games and comic books that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect way to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just will let you know they're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Eternals plot leak in the comment
section below the winner will be chosen
at random October the 15th and the blue
arrow be shipped out from the end
whoever gets the prize so best of luck
to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]